horror fans rejoiced when the nun was
announced in June 2016 billed as the
darkest chapter in the conjuring
universe the film is the fifth
installment in the fast growing horror
franchise and it centers around a
demonic character featured briefly in
the conjuring 2 and Annabel creation I
have survived many terrifying encounters
from the characters origins and
real-life demon Lords to spooky
behind-the-scenes stories from the cast
and crew this is the untold truth of the
nun from music to mayhem British
director Corrin Hardy didn't have tons
of experience when director and producer
James Wan asked him to join the
conjuring universe team but Hardy's 2015
feature film debut the hallow proved he
was capable of great things
the consensus on Rotten Tomatoes is that
the hallow promised a wonderfully
horrifying future for director Kourt and
Hardy
prior to the hallow Hardy had been
plying his trade in music videos between
2007 and 2011 the director created
hallucinatory clips for bands like The
Prodigy his very first music video even
hinted at an interest in the McCobb the
video for she is the new thing by the
horrors is a refreshingly creepy clip
but bigger creepier things were on the
way strange bedfellows therefore I
assume that which was not boob you said
based on Umberto eCos best-selling novel
the 1986 melodrama the name of the rose
star Sean Connery is William of
Baskerville the fictional friar is often
thought to be a mash-up of Sherlock
Holmes and Middle Ages philosopher
William of Ockham Christian Slater plays
Baskervilles apprentice and both men are
investigating the unexplained death of a
famous monk the plot thickens when the
last person who spoke to the monk is
also found dead in a vat of pig blood
and the residents of the abbey fear the
devil is it worth James Wan told The
Hollywood Reporter that the nun is like
the name of the rose crossed with the
conjuring the similarities between the
stories are clear both films have a
religious historical setting and both
involve a member of the church arriving
at a strange place to solve a mysterious
murder one major difference in the nun a
supernatural force is actually behind
the mayhem get to know Valli the nun is
a product of James wons imagination but
the demonic being is rooted in real-life
lore the demons name gives us power rich
in the classic occult texts the Lesser
Key of Solomon Ballack has given the
title grande president of hell and
assumes the form of a winged child
riding a two-headed dragon that sounds
epic but maybe not for a haunted house
movie
so far VALIC has taken multiple forms in
the conjuring universe in fact the demon
briefly becomes the crooked man in the
conjuring 2
does this mean Edie and Lorraine Warren
will eventually have a final showdown
with a creepy kid on a dragon let's hope
not Vande equals buzz in the early days
of YouTube jump scare videos were all
over the place like a throwback to those
simpler times a controversial
seven-second ad appeared on YouTube a
few weeks before the nones release date
first a volume icon appeared in the
middle of the users screen viewers were
only given a few seconds before a
shrieking nun popped up to scare the
bejesus out of them the ad didn't sit
well with everyone one Twitter user even
suggested it could be dangerous writing
if you see an ad on YouTube with the
volume sign being turned down and
nothing else it's a jump scare for the
new nun movie coming out please retweet
to save a life the warning was retweeted
over 100,000 times forcing YouTube to
respond the company removed the ad for
violating its shocking content policy
which was ultimately fantastic publicity
for the film
thanks jump-scare truth or scare during
her comic-con interview with
Entertainment Tonight taissa farmiga
explained why she's frightened by the
occult I don't know what I believe about
supernatural and ghosts but on the kind
of person that's like why open the doors
when I let it in because then I'll get
an answer and I don't want a definite
answer the one person who really seems
to believe in ghosts is Koren Hardy in
fact he told cinema blend he saw two
real ghosts while filming a scene in a
Romanian fortress I go into the room and
as I went into the room I see these two
guys from the crew you know I'm probably
sound Department just so sitting a
little further back in the dark
arty says he greeted the men and then
sat with his back to them while getting
a shot but the real terror was yet to
come
half an hour later he turned around and
there was just no one in the room and
then and there haven't been anyone in
there after look there's no way they
could have come we can only guess what
happened next
you
[Music]